well you see the painting and it's
spectacular it was drawn by las vegas
resident neil portney
you're gonna see it in just a second
he's a talented artist who specializes
in sports chris matthews caught up with
the artist who talks about his work in a
huge drawing that
covers an entire wall in the legion
stadium
well you know what being from boston
having lived there my whole life
i get to watch tom brady for 20 years do
this
so i'm sitting at the drawing board i
got a couple days before any commission
works coming in
and i said you know what i got to do a
super bowl piece so i start
the process for me researching photos
because i work from photographs
found a good head and shoulders of brady
found one of patrick mahomes
and then i started illustrating i went
you know what i don't want to just do
the two of them i got to put the coaches
in because the coaches are the
personalities
and then i'm like all right now i got to
do what's the logo for the super bowl i
gotta find that
and then i did a little silhouette if
you look really closely at the drawing
it's the tamper bay skyline
of the silhouette so now it's the
balancing act now you got to kind of
design it
and you know i work with magic markers
and unlike oils acrylics and watercolors
where you can mix colors
markers of steam so you put it down it's
down
so now you're talking tight little areas
and
you know i'm old at this stage you know
i can only do two hours at a time
whatever before the eyes go
and i really got into this piece and
chris i think it's one of the best
pieces i've ever done
people would always ask me what's the
best piece you've done
and i answer it the same way every time
the next one
well you know what this was the next one
and
and we had talked to earlier you know i
got to call my old friend
and say hey how can we use this in your
broadcast
well it looks terrific and i think you
know you mentioned the skyline the two
quarterbacks but boy the two coaches
also
just the detail with those coaches in
the background looks good
thanks it's amazing you smell those
things for 10 minutes the market you'll
be just like me
i'm an ex-baseball player i'm a jock who
happens to be able to draw
so it's like when i'm doing a football
player i've played the game
you know not to the ability of these two
guys
but at least i know what i'm drawing and
i think that's a huge advantage
when i when i do sports and i've done
you know every major sport
how many uh paintings have you done of
tom brady
um excuse me i did a beautiful one of
him with gillette in the background
action poses and then the the butler
interception game
with seattle i illustrated a super bowl
piece
on that one um and i've done some
cartoons with him before in the past
uh i have always said that robert kraft
should
own all of my patriot artwork because at
gillette stadium they have a beautiful
exhibit in their hall of fame i should
be the illustrator for their hall of
fame
who knows you don't know what's going to
happen well let me at speaking of
stadiums and beautiful drawings talk
about your drawing that sits inside a
legion stadium right now
where someday fans will get to go in
there and see it
well it's called raiders through the
years it
features 28 i believe
the greatest names in raiders history
and it's a collage
of all of the players and it's blown up
28 by
40 feet in a legion stadium
i have not seen it yet i've had workers
come to me say hey we saw your piece in
the stadium
and then you know there's a
non-disclosure agreement technically
although
people have posted it i'm not allowed to
say
that because mark davis supports the
arts
wonderful to the art community has got a
number of artists
from michael garden the great michael
garden
to a number of local talent that have
pieces
in the stadium mine just happens to be
the largest one
well that's terrific let me ask you
final question neil
uh who do you like in the super bowl
tampa bay yeah
listen i i think um with the spread's
like three and a half or something
and you and patrick mahone is still the
wild card
but i've learned as somebody from boston
for 20 years
you do not bet against tom brady he's
the goat
thanks so much chris still to come